>>> JOINING US NOW, FORMER NEW
JERSEY GOVERNOR CHRIS CHRISTIE,
OUT WITH A BRAND-NEW MEMOIR.
NEW JERSEY, AND THE POWER OF
IN-YOUR-FACE POLITICS AVAILABLE
ON AMAZON.COM WHEREVER BOOKS ARE
SOLD.
HOW ARE YOU?
>> GOOD.
HOW ARE YOU, SEAN?
>> Sean: DO WE REALLY NEED 27
FBI AGENTS, TACTICAL GEAR, 17
VEHICLES INCLUDING ARMORED
VEHICLES TO ARREST A GUY THAT
HAS NO WEAPONS IN HIS HOUSE, A
GUY THAT IS CHARGED WITH LYING
TO CONGRESS?
>> NO.
LISTEN, YOU KNOW THAT I'VE
DEFENDED MUELLER OVER THE KOURS
OF TIME OVER THE LAST -- COURSE
OF TIME.
>> Sean: HOW CAN YOU DEFEND THIS
MAN?
>> I CAN'T DEFEND THIS.
>> Sean: EVERY APPOINTMENT AS A
DEMOCRAT.
>> I CAN'T DEFEND ANDREW
WEISMAN.
I WOULDN'T DEFEND ANDREW
THIS IS A PROBLEM FOR BOB
MUELLER.
>> Sean: HOW DOES HE HIRE
CLINTON FOUNDATION ATTORNEYS?
>> ALMOST EVERY ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE CAME FROM INSIDE THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
PART OF THAT PROBLEM IS, THERE
WAS NO TURNOVER WHEN JEFF
SESSIONS WAS ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
GET NEW PEOPLE INTO POSITIONS.
WEISMAN IS STILL HEAD OF THE
FRAUD --
>> Sean: OVERTURNED FIFTH
CIRCUIT, 9-0 LOSS IN THE SUPREME
COURT.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF ENRON
ACCOUNTING EMPLOYEES.
>> OF COURSE.
TO ME, WHY WAS HE STILL IN THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO BEGIN
WITH.
>> Sean: WAIT A MINUTE.
THIS WAS MUELLER'S CHOICE TO PUT
WEISMAN AND JEANNIE RAY ON THIS
TEAM.
>> I'M NOT DEFENDING THAT.
THE RAID IS WRONG.
IF HE DID NOT HAVE WEAPONS IN
THAT HOUSE, THERE IS NO REASON
TO GO WITH TACTICAL UNITS, WITH
FLAK JACKETS ON, AUTOMATIC
WEAPONS AND ALL THE REST.
THERE'S NO REASON FOR IT EXCEPT
TO INTIMIDATE.
THAT'S THE ONLY REASON TO DO IT.
THAT IS AN ABSOLUTE
INAPPROPRIATE USE OF
PROSECUTORIAL AUTHORITY.
>> Sean: YOU TALK ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT THOUGHT IN GENERAL
FLYNN WAS FIRED, THE WHOLE
RUSSIA THING'S OVER.
ONLY NOT THE CASE.
>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: ONE OF THE REASONS YOU
DON'T BELIEVE IT, AS EVERY
CAMPAIGN IS, THERE'S CHAOS.
NOBODY HAS TIME TO SAY LET ME
MEET WITH PUTIN.
>> LISTEN.
I WAS THERE FOR A GOOD PART OF
THE CAMPAIGN, AS YOU KNOW.
AS I SAID, THIS WAS A CAMPAIGN
AND YOU KNOW ABOUT THIS
CAMPAIGN.
I SAY THIS IN AN ADMIRING WAY,
HAVING LOST TO THEM.
THIS WAS NOT A TRADITIONAL
ORGANIZED CAMPAIGN.
THEY WERE NOT GOING TO DO SOME
TOM CLANCY ROUTINE STILL TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO HIRE FIELD
OPERATORS IN PENNSYLVANIA.
THAT CAMPAIGN WON BECAUSE OF THE
POWER AND THE IDEAS AND THE
ARTICULATION OF DONALD TRUMP.
THAT'S WHAT YOU HEAR FROM ME IN
THIS BOOK.
>> Sean: HE TALKED TO YOU ABOUT
BEING VICE PRESIDENT.
>> IT WAS DOWN TO ME AND MIKE
PENCE.
>> Sean: YOU MENTION ME IN THE
BOOK.
THANKS A LOT.
>> YOU'RE PART OF THE STORY.
>> Sean: I LOVE BEING MENTIONED
IN THE BOOK.
WHY DO YOU TELL STORIES -- LIKE
THE STORY ABOUT -- TO ME IT'S
LIKE, THAT'S SORT OF PRIVATE --
>> I THINK -- FIRST OF ALL, IT
WASN'T BECAUSE THERE WERE A
WHOLE BUNCH OF PEOPLE.
>> Sean: YOU DIDN'T HAVE TO PUT
IT IN A BOOK.
>> I THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT
THING TO SHOW THIS PRESIDENT'S
HUMANITY AND SHOW HIS SENSE OF
HUMOR.
I THINK HE'S DRAWN BY THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA AS A CARTOON
CHARACTER.
THIS IS A GUY WHO'S A GREAT
FATHER AND LOVES HIS CHILDREN.
I TELL THOSE STORIES IN THE BOOK
ABOUT HIS GENUINE CONCERN WHAT
AFFECT THIS WAS GOING TO HAVE ON
HIS KIDS AND HIS KIDS BEING
SUCCESSFUL IN THE BUSINESS AND
HIM ALWAYS BEING THERE FOR THEM
AND NOW HE WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO.
I TALK ABOUT THE FACT THAT HE IS
THE FIRST PERSON THAT SAID
ACROSS FROM ME AND SAID, CHRIS,
YOU NEED TO GET LAP BAND
SURGERY.
YEARS BEFORE I DECIDED TO DO IT.
I'M TRYING TO SHOW THE HUMANITY
OF DONALD TRUMP.
PEOPLE DRAW HIM LIKE A CARTOON
CHARACTER.
>> Sean: YOU'RE A PROSECUTOR.
DID HILLARY CLINTON VIOLATE THE
ESPIONAGE ACT WITH THAT SERVER?
>> YES.
>> Sean: DID HILLARY CLINTON
OBSTRUCT JUSTICE --
>> SHE DELETED THE E-MAILS WHILE
THE SUBPOENA WAS PENDING, THEN
YES.
>> Sean: DO WE NOT HAVE ALL
BRENNAN, CLAPPER, ALL THESE
PEOPLE THAT I MENTIONED, DID
THEY NOT LIE TO CONGRESS AND GOT
CAUGHT, HOW COME THEY DON'T GET
THE RAIDS IN THIS CASE?
>> WHY DON'T YOU TAKE AN HOUR
ONE NIGHT AND HAVE JEFF SESSIONS
ON HERE AND ASK HIM THOSE
QUESTIONS.
>> Sean: I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE
WAS DOING.
I WOULD LIKE TO --
>> THAT'S MY POINT.
>> Sean: IT TURNED INTO A
DISASTER.
>> WHO YOU PICKED AS ATTORNEY
GENERAL MATTERS.
IT'S ONE OF THE THINGS I TALK
ABOUT IN THE BOOK.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
VICTIMIZED BY SOME BAD CHOICES
THAT WERE RECOMMENDED TO HIM AND
BY A PROCESS THAT DIDN'T WORK
WELL FOR HIM.
>> Sean: AREN'T YOU WORRIED AS A
FORMER PROSECUTE
FORMER PROSECUTOR AND GOVERNOR,
WE HAVE A DUAL JUSTICE SYSTEM,
WE HAVE ALL THESE OTHER PEOPLE
THAT LIED UNDER OATH TO
CONGRESS, NOTHING HAPPENS -- FOR
EXAMPLE, HILLARY FUNNELS MONEY,
HER CAMPAIGN MONEY, THROUGH A
LAW FIRM -- SO IT'S LEGAL
EXPENSE -- TO HIRE A RESEARCH
GROUP, QATAR FOREIGN NATIONALS,
RUSSIAN LIES THAT THEY SPREAD TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, AND THEN
THEY USE IT TO BLUDGEN THE
PRESIDENT EVER SINCE.
THAT HE LEARNED HILLARY PAID FOR
IT AND THAT IT'S UNVERIFIED.
HOW DO YOU NOT VERIFY -- AND IT
TURNS OUT A LOT OF IT IS LIES.
HOOKERS, RITZ CARLTON, HOW DO
THEY GET AWAY WITH ALL OF THAT
AND MUELLER PAYS NO ATTENTION TO
IT?
>> FIRST OF ALL, WE DON'T KNOW
WHETHER HE HAS OR HAS THE YET.
>> Sean: I DON'T SEE IT AT ALL.
>> WE DON'T KNOW YET.
LET'S WAIT FOR THE REPORT.
HERE'S THE OTHER THING.
LET'S SAY HE ISN'T PAYING
ATTENTION IT --
>> MUELLER HIRES A TEAM OF
DEMOCRATS AND A -- AND CLINTON'S
OWN FORMER ATTORNEY.
>> I'M NOT DEFENDING THOSE
HIRINGS.
WHAT I'M SAYING TO YOU IS, IF IN
FACT THAT'S WHAT'S GOING ON AND
MUELLER IS INDEPENDENT OF --
>> Sean: THEY TRUST -- WHY WOULD
MUELLER PUT THAT TEAM TOGETHER?
>> HERE'S WHAT I BELIEVE.
RIGHT FROM THE BEGINNING, THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT UNDER DONALD
TRUMP WAS NOT RUN THE WAY IT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN.
>> Sean: OKAY.
I GOT THAT POINT.
>> THERE WAS MAYHEM.
>>.
>> Sean: LAST QUESTION.
>> THE MOST IMPORTANT THING YOU
SAID TO TONIGHT AND THE REASON
TO ANSWER THE QUESTION, OF
COURSE I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T HAVE A FAIR
JUSTICE SYSTEM --
>> Sean: WE DON'T.
>> -- DEMOCRACY IS OVER.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY --
>> Sean: LAST QUESTION.
FISA COURT, THERE WAS A
CONSPIRACY TO COMMIT FRAUD.
THEY NEVER VERIFIED THE LIES
THAT THEY PUT IN THE DOCUMENT.
THEY MINIMIZED HILLARY'S
INVOLVEMENT.
SHOULDN'T ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE
NOW THEMSELVES PAY THAT PRICE?
>> EVERY ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THAT SHOULD
BE --
>> Sean: COMEY, ROD ROSENSTEIN.
>> -- TO EXACTLY THE SAME
SCRUTINY THAT BOB MUELLER --
>> Sean: IT'S NOT HAPPENING.
>> THAT'S WHY I HOPE THAT THE
NEW ATTORNEY GENERAL THAT THE
PRESIDENT -- WILL DO THIS.
GUESS WHAT.
THIS IS THE JOB OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL OF THE UNITED STATES.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE HAD?
WE HAD ONE OF THE BEST ATTORNEY
GENERALS THIS COUNTRY EVER HAD
IN JOHN ASHCROFT.
AT A TIME WHEN OUR COUNTRY WAS
IN GREAT DANGER, HE EMPOWERED
HIS U.S. ATTORNEYS TO ATTACK